[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones at
88255 225 that's
5225 five you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Jade washaw
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
and you jump in we'll help you out it's
what we're here for Dante is with us in
Orlando Florida hi Dante welcome to the
ramsy show hi Dave it's an honor to be
speaking with you you too what's up so
um real quickly I my cousin gifted me
two tickets for this weekend's Tennessee
and Florida football
game they're really good seats and the
value is about $800 that we can resell
them for is it morally wrong for me to
sell those by super tickets it is yeah
okay he didn't he didn't give them to
you as your side gig he gave them to you
to use you give them back to him okay
well I don't want to give them back I
want to use them okay if you want to use
them that's fine but I mean I'd give
them back but no I wouldn't sell that
the joy was him the joy for him was you
going to that game and so if you don't
want to use him then his Joy will be
somebody else going that game I got you
fair enough yeah they're they're his
they're not yours I got you can I ask
you a second question real quick kind of
off topic of this one that was very easy
I have a couple 401ks that have like a
few thousand dollars from past previous
employers should I combine them all into
one with my my current player or TR just
leave them alone uh I always just roll
old 401ks to
Ira and um just get with your
smartvestor pro and they can help you
start an account to do all your older
rollovers into and that's where all mine
are uh they're all in Ira if they were
Roth 401ks they'll become Roth IRAs if
they were traditional IRAs they'll
become traditional
401ks so that's an interesting question
though going back to his football thing
for a second yes CU I saw that we we get
to see a little bit of like a half a
sentence from uh from our associate
producer Austin he tells us a little bit
about what you're calling about and uh
so but so I kind of thought I want what
under what
circumstances if you won the tickets
from a radio station you would be able
to sell them I agree that's not that's
not a thing okay um but like if uh like
I had a Titan suite for a while uhhuh
okay and I gave one of my people that
worked here at Ramsey two of the tickets
okay if they took those and resold those
that would be not okay yeah that's not
why I gave them to them it was not them
money if I want to give them money I
would give them money or you might just
tell them like uh I give people tennis
shoes sometimes cuz I love Jordan shoes
and if I give them I'll say hey I don't
care if you sell them do whatever you
want with them but here give them
permission I'll give them permission if
you do care you know if you don't care
maybe it's a good thing to say but like
we actually had uh Predators tickets
that the company owned and uh there's a
drawing every week for uh an employee
benefit okay just to just to you know
just something nice to do for the team
right yeah um it got to where nobody
wanted to go for some reason so we don't
have it anymore but uh but one time one
of those team members took those tickets
and sold them and I thought that was
wrong you did you I was I would have
said that that would have been okay
really okay but Dave technically you
bought the tickets let's be honest about
me I gave them to you as an employee
benefit I didn't give them to you as a
fundraiser that's a good point if I
donated them as a fundraiser for your
get out of debt plan it'd be different
right yeah you could use them or you
could do whatever but a matter of fact
I'd rather you didn't use them then that
you used them to get out of debt but I
don't know under what circumstances I
guess I guess a if they tell you sell
yeah they say I don't care what you do
with it I don't care what you do with
them I'm sick of this I don't want them
I'm not going you can you can burn them
you can sell them you can use them I
think the quality of what the gift is
like like you said a a box box seats
well I mean that's a big deal yeah I
mean if it was a $5 ticket or something
but I'm just saying you wouldn't bother
sell that but those $800 but um for the
Florida game but um okay here's another
caveat if it causes them to have to
spend money in order to enjoy
it then they should be able to get out
of it so if you say hey oh yeah but I
would say that to back to the person as
I gave them back to him yeah yeah you're
the kind of guy that would do that
though like you would give them an out
some people yeah I would just say hey I
can't do I can't take these cuz I can't
spend the money to drive to Knoxville
for the game okay or whatever it is in
that case um but interesting a little
bit of communication goes along away
with these things the guy might not care
if you called him and said hey I'm kind
of 50/50 I'm thinking about selling him
but I wouldn't want to do that unless
you were okay with it yeah he that might
be a way to handle it that's true but
then that's so awkward for the other
person cuz what are they going to say
like no just give them back to me yeah I
would oh I would definitely do that I
straight up if you call me and say No I
gave them to you and if you don't want
to use them it's okay give them back
I'll find somebody wants to use them
yeah that is that's good yeah that's an
interesting one Dave yeah you got to
give the you got to say hey this is for
you I you know I love you know whatever
it is I love Beyonce I'd love for you to
have these tickets you and your wife
enjoy then that's a clear use the
tickets they're for you to enjoy if they
say hey this is for you I don't care if
you sell it I'm not going to use it do
whatever you want with it then you have
the yeah the clear out trying to think
of the other one oh I know what happened
one time I gave a guy tickets and he did
sell them and so these strangers come
into my
box that bought the tickets off the
street oh that's terrible see that's
even worse that's and then you got to
sit and talk to them they like they're
in my private box man I mean it's like
we had a we that's that's why you get
one oh that's terrible oh man and and
they're oh and and I have to be nice to
them you know because then they'll have
a Dave story otherwise right there's
another side to this Dave cuz this is
making me go this is like okay you get
it this is like a this is like a
Christmas gift
right reting Rachel that's Rachel's
nickname regifting Rachel but not look
my mother-in-law if she gets something
she's going to look for it in the house
oh so I can't give you got to watch
Rachel she'll give you back the next
year what you gave her last year and not
remember it and not remember it she's
straight up regifting Rachel I think I
heard her tell a story about giving the
person the gift back she's done it more
than once that's hilarious so there you
go so it runs in the family so I can't
really say much to you Dante but it's uh
if my own kids are doing it but uh
that's interesting under what
circumstances number one we got to have
some principles here how are we can't be
a wrapped gift it has to be something
I'm saying with the tickets under what
with the tickets if you asked or if they
said yep it was okay then it would be
okay for sure okay that that's
circumstances um yeah and and for sure
don't create um you're not creating
awkwardness like selling the public a
box in a private seats in a private box
or something that's yes that's like so
freaking strange yeah oh I'll tell you
I'll tell you one too okay if you give
that guy the tickets this is this is
different than selling them and then he
just doesn't use them oh well that's
even worse and they're worth 800 bucks a
p that's even that's the worst of the
worst burn you they just burn them yeah
and it's like I could have given them
somebody would liked to have gone yeah
you took took them and threw them in the
track that that's just rude that's
that's going to be rude that's there's a
lot of ticket etiquette going on today
there we go this is the ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsy Solutions
on the debt free stage Douglas is with
us hi Douglas how are you happy to be
here Dave honored to have you man honor
to have you love your T-shirt pleasure
is discipline equals Freedom well done
amen so where do you live I live in
small town of Sonora California oh very
nice that's a nice area it is and uh how
much debt have you paid off Douglas
$192,000 all right how long did that
take uh from uh uh your Financial Peace
University it was 5 years five months
all right I love it and uh what was your
average or your range of income during
that time uh $56,000 I now make 87,000
way to go yes sir what you for a living
I drive big red I'm an engineer
firefighter with st Consolidated Fire
Protection District outside of Modesto
it wow look at that photo what kind of
debt was the uh 192 it's the weirdest
debt you'd ever hear of it is uh my
house hey let's
go well we're looking at weird people
with a
paid a big red driver with a paid for
house baby game on yes sir I love it
congratulations congratulations well
tell us the story what started this
journey 5 years ago uh started the
journey basically um I had a new
engineer bid in with us and uh he he
said have you heard of this Dave Ramsey
guy I'm like no and he's like well you
got to check him out I was like H okay
well he he got me into FPU he's right
here with us
today and uh he got me into FPU we did
FPU and uh then also one of my interns
it turns out uh he got hired uh with
Modesta he he ran our table during FPU
he's also with us today to celebrate you
as well all right that's awesome very
cool very cool where did you take the
class uh we took the class at a church
in Modesto I don't remember the name of
the church but it was uh it was it was
wonderful uh we had uh this might make
you laugh a little bit 35 credit cards
on our table wow there it is chop them
chop them get them rid of them serious
plastic surgery well done that's 5 years
ago your income over 5 Years agoes From
56 up to 87 and you just keep plinking
on the house yeah yes sir did you have
any other debt when you started uh I was
I had a little bit of stupid because I
had been told you have to have a credit
card to buy a house and we both know
that ain't true and uh so there was just
like a $100 to $200 on that but yeah
that was gone immediately so it's just a
matter of saying okay I'm going to line
up for the Long Haul again going to do a
little Marathon run here a little
fiveyear run and knock the house out how
old are you I'm 46 years old how old
what's this house worth this house is
now worth uh last I saw 340,000 good for
you and how much you got in retirement
uh retirement now well I have my Pur uh
retirement and then I have uh currently
50,000 okay for you man going to have
that well done you've done great
congratulations thank you and all making
56 to 87 yes sir sir yes sir so you paid
off your house I'm just struggling I'm
just my mind is blown by this five and a
half years basically most people do that
when they get intense in about seven
years what how did you do this and what
would you say to other people CU most
people 46 it doesn't matter if you're 46
56 they don't understand this idea of
paying off your house and they certainly
don't understand how in the world
someone could do it in 5 years and five
months well if I could share like I
would love to share that feeling um of
the freedom you get once you do it if if
if if people could just have 5 Seconds
of that um they never go back you would
never go back uh there were
there were days where you would put in
like our our typical shift we work a 48
hour shift and then we're off
96 um there were times where I'd put in
six S 8 10 24-hour shifts just to knock
it out um that was a big part of it um
the big part for me um was like you said
uh you inspired me so much with changing
that family tree I want something to
give away to my family someday when I'm
when I'm able to find that lady and and
have my family it's going to be amazing
yeah way too that's so Co proud of you
man thank you sir good work all right
when somebody says uh you know new guy
comes on the shift and you go um now
you're the guy bothering like your buddy
over there right um hey you got to try
this ramsy stuff what do you tell them
the secret to getting out of dead is I
got a paid for house I'm 46 well we
actually had that conversation with
firefighter Baker the other day uh we
already showed him every dollar when I
get back I want to put him through
Financial Peace University uh the main
thing being is is to stay stay focused
um pay attention to the people around
you and uh the main thing being is just
you have to believe that you can do it
and knock those other voices out around
you block them out those saying oh it's
good Deb you have to have thatb no no
you don't in California nobody has a
paid for house this guy does except
Douglas except dougl yeah yes and now I
think my biggest problem is is trying
not to you know be in too much of over
it you know you have to like slip in in
a bit hey you're heard FPU hey you're
heard Ry you want to just take your
baseball bat and go hey wake up knock
them on the side of the head I love it
that's great thank you man thank you
very much we appreciate it we're so
proud of you thank you we've got the
live and give box for you and that's the
baby steps millionaires book that's your
next step for sure yes and The Total
Money Makeover uh for you to give away
and maybe get somebody started and I'll
give you a Financial Peace University in
that kit and you use it for firefighter
Baker that wayf abolutely absolutely
knock him on the head with it hit him
with the box and then hand him that and
I I'd like to say one thing one more
thing before I do my screen I want to
thank my family this my father my mother
they came down with me from Virginia
today that's the man that taught me how
to work that's my hero if you want to
know who a firefighter hero is he's
right there and he's also right there so
there there you have it proud of you g
well done well done and I know your dad
is excellent stuff and your mom good
good good work all right Douglas from
Sonora California how do you do it you
work consecutive 24s whoa M yeah 5 years
5 months paid off
192,000 house and everything and yes I
did say California 56,000 to 87,000 As A
Firefighter count it down let's hear a
debt free Scream 3 2 1 I'm de
[Applause]
free this is how you do it in Sonora
right here I'm just saying that's great
wow powerful that was something he
almost knocked himself over with that
scream that was intense that's what I'm
talking
about well I tell you uh the first
responder Community uh in general I was
just talking to one of our entree guys
he was speaking to one of the large
Sheriff's departments there in
California last weekend and uh several
of them came up to him after he was
leading he was leading a workshop for
him and said that you know they've been
following our stuff and several of them
were millionaires that's awesome and so
the the First Responders Community does
a
really uh the ones that know how to that
lean in that they do an excellent job of
applying these principles I could see
that it's very it's a very Community
Driven bunch of people and all it takes
like he said is one guy getting in there
and say hey let me show you what worked
putting their arm around him I love the
language that they use with Financial
Peace he put me in he put me into
Financial Peace and now I'm going to put
him into F it's like you you literally
take them with you grab them by the arm
going with me fireman carry over the
here we go here we go that's right yeah
it's uh good that we do that on uh by
the way for those of you tuning in by uh
one of the 9 million methods we have out
there we're taping this broadcasting
this on September the 11th so to honor a
firefighter on that day for that free
scream is really really appropriate and
honor the First Responders in any way we
can cuz that was an I'm old enough I
remember that very viscerally uh some of
you weren't born yet I know but for you
it's like Pearl Harbor it's some kind of
distant history thing but for uh for
those of us that remember watching those
uh cowards fly those planes into those
Towers um it's something we will never
forget the feeling in our chest the
feeling down the back of our neck and uh
then watching those Heroes go in and
save people and attempt Tove people and
uh it was it was a wild Wild event to
say the least and thanks to all of you
that serve and as First Responders out
there you're amazing people
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Pao is giving you 90 days
free imagine the peaceful habits you can
establish in 90 days go to hall.com
Ramsey today and follow the simple
prompts to start your free 90-day trial
that's hall.com
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Washington DC is calling
Alicia is with us hi Alicia how are
you hi hi well thank you I hope you are
doing well happy Monday happy Monday How
can I
help um I'm going through a little bit
of a moral uh dilemma I guess when it
comes to between uh making choices uh
with money and with what to do with a
personal
situation okay um basically
um
I've made some mistakes I've gone
through
some blunders whatever you want to call
them had to pay them off I only have
about
46,000 left in debt it's half and half
between student loans and credit
cards
um
I am
wondering I guess I'm GNA summarize um
basically my dad is um very very sick
they the doctors think this will be his
last
year sorry and I think I I can't afford
to do all the things that he wants and
wishes like travel and meet up and all
these things however also his last year
this will probably be our last Christmas
together and I'm trying to figure out
and budget like to um seee as much as I
can I live a thousand miles away from
him over that um actually but um anyway
um I guess when it comes to situations
like that in life like what where do you
even
start what do you
do I'm sorry so where does he
live Minnesota and what's the nature of
his
illness pancreatic
cancer that's
tough okay um and what do you make a
year it's varied um the last few
years and is currently varying because
I've had to take time off because I've
gotten sick myself um I guess if you
were ballpark at let's say uh 70k I'm
critical care nurse okay all right what
was the nature of your
illness uh stupid things from limes
disease to uh kidney infections to um
those don't sound stupid they sound
that's chronic does sounds stupid it
sounds pretty rough yeah it sounds
serious okay and so he's wanting to he's
wanting to see you you're wanting to see
him uh with this diagnosis that makes a
lot of sense um you also mention he's
wanting to do a lot of things I can't
afford to do what does that
mean I
am I I've already cancelled all my
subscriptions no I said he's wanting I
thought you said he's wanting to do a
lot of things that you can't afford to
do what is he asking to do that you
can't afford to
do so to Colorado visit him in his new
place at esus Park um so he's in
Minnesota in
Colorado um great question I don't even
know he goes back and forth does he have
two residences he has two
houses he has businesses out in Florida
Colorado Minesota and I think
Arizona so does he have a lot of
money yes okay and what is it he's
wanting you to do other than spend time
with him
for his last you know he wants to see
you know his family all like together
and happy together okay so it's you
going on some trips buying the flights
to go to Colorado or buying the flights
to go to Florida not we're not going to
Japan in Australia
right um not necessarily true um I mean
we took a trip to Germany
but I'm saying is there anything is
there anything that has been planned
other than hey you might have to buy
some trips some flights over here to
Colorado my dad's a last minute guy
okaya let's stop a second all right
there's two things going on all right
number one is it valid to desire and
figure out a way to spend time with your
dad in his last year of Life
absolutely is it valid for him to pull
everyone's strings and put you so far in
debt when he has money to accomplish
this goal that's selfish on his part M
so if he wants to spend time with you in
Germany and he's a last minute guy he
needs to be buying the tickets M he has
the money you
don't Dad I can't afford to do this I
love you I would love to spend some time
with you I will drive to Minnesota when
you're there that's the closest point or
I will drive to Florida when you're
there that's the be even better um I can
do that in one day it's 1,000 miles I'll
just get in the car and come and I can
spend a couple of three days with you
and then I'll have to come back and go
to work that's what real people do in
situations like
this yeah there's nothing you don't get
to just make up
finances if they don't exist because
this is a horrible sad
situation yeah and on your part there's
nothing wrong with getting with your
family members and saying let's make a
plan like let's plan this out what do we
want to do what do we plan to do that
way we can all decide if it fits in our
budget and we can make changes if we
need to because if he really does want
to see you guys and spend time with you
guys and that's the that's the point
then that's what's going to happen but
you got to be proactive 20 years ago my
father-in-law decided he was going to
pay for the whole family to get together
once a year we call it the family
reunion no duh and he pays for the whole
deal it's nothing fancy it's at our
Lakehouse but he pays for the food the
gas and whatever none of us need his
money all of us have enough that we're
just fine but it's his great pleasure in
life to make sure he gets everyone
together he's 94 this year no one will
miss and he will still pay for it
because we can't make him not pay for it
it's part of the joy of him Gathering
everyone together and paying for it
that's how this works in the real world
okay but we do it in a place that we can
afford and that everyone can pull off um
you know he he's not asking everyone to
go to Japan P who's
broke because he's impulsive that's
weird okay I know so you need to set
some boundaries with your dad loving and
say I am more than willing to spend time
with you I cannot I do not have the
finances to follow you around all over
the world if you want me to do that
you're going to have to buy the ticket
dad and it's okay if you don't want to
but it doesn't you cannot say that means
I don't want to see you cuz I'll get in
the car and drive to Florida when you're
there and see you I'll see you I'll
spend time with you but it's it's not
required that we do that in an exotic
expensive location it's just required
that we spend T IIM together that's how
you spell
love
tiim and it's not it's not exotic that's
not how you spell it yeah that's good
that's good and so I'm sorry honey I'm
sorry you're all facing this tough but
the way and and I'm sorry your dad's
having to um nav navigate these emotions
and he's struggling to do that properly
so you've just got to be loving and kind
and say Dad I want to spend time with
you I'll have to do it in a way that I
can afford to do it I don't have the
money and if you want to do something
impulsive I if I can take time off I
will if you're a last minute kind of guy
um which by the way if I had one year
I'd be a last minute kind of guy yeah
absolutely for the whole freaking Year
all the time I'd be calling people up
and going going where you want to go
everybody load up yeah I know I don't
mind that but I'm also paying for it
you're paying for it yeah that's true
and I'm not asking broke people that I
love to go in debt and it sounds like he
to fund a memory yeah he's got the money
yeah so yeah he's got businesses all
over the place houses all over the
placers yeah so that that's this is the
proper use of this it's not you don't
use well that I'm sorry I'm sorry you're
facing this yeah
awful that puts us hour the Ramsey Show
in the
[Music]
books
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramseys
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
take your questions at
[Music]
88255 225
now last
fall not quite a year ago now I think it
was November if I recall uh we did
a fabulously attended free live stream
on real
estate interest rates had not yet
climbed to where they are now uh but the
uh coid Rush the uh fouy pandemic
quarantine Rush had eased Ed and the
real estate market was cooling off
because interest rates had ticked up and
people were freaking out acting like the
real estate market was going to crash
and that prices were going to go down
I'll just wait till prices go down and
we were addressing that we had this big
podcast um you were of course here you
were still in your first few months with
us at that point and uh it was very
successful we had I think a couple
hundred thousand folks watch that view
or watch that live stream I call it a
podcast that live stream and in it we
went through the details of the real
estate situation and explained very
carefully how dramatically the supply of
housing is below the demand and that
anytime there is a demand for anything
that is higher than the supply if you
took economics in the seventh grade they
taught you that that means the prices
will go up mhm when demand exceeds
Supply prices will go up the more demand
exceeds Supply the more prices will go
up and as long as that is the perception
in the market then it's prices are going
to go up that's what's going to happen
and so we told you house prices are not
going to tank as a matter of fact
they're probably going to go up in 2023
about 7% now at that time we had two
types of house prices floating around we
had the people that had priced their
house way high and unrealistically
hoping to catch a sucker cuz there were
a bunch of suckers out there buying
property for anything and everything way
above appraisal yes okay that is not an
actual price that's a sucker yes that's
not a price and so uh now but and then
there were people that had priced their
homes at or around appraisal we were not
talking about sucker prices we were
talking about appraisal prices are not
going to come down we said you can
expect to see people calling prices
going down but really what it is it's
the asking price that's going down
because people quit uh fishing for
suckers MH that's right okay and they
get more realistic and you're going to
expect to see instead of 8 minutes uh
time on the market you can expect 80 or
90 days time on the market which has
been typical for the last 50 years in
the real estate market that you mow the
grass you trim the bushes you paint the
kidss weird bedroom and you vacuum and
you steam clean and you clean out the
garage and you clean out the closets and
you put fresh light bulbs in and you put
your house on the market at a good price
based on what your good competent real
estate agent tells you to put it on at
and it will sell in 80 to 90 days for
the last 50 years with rare exceptions
keyword competent yeah and then yeah
keyword competent and keyword that you
priced it properly that's right okay so
we told you a year ago that you're not
going to see house price is going to go
down we think they're going to go up
around 7% they went up 27% the year
before but that was based on the fouchy
uh pandemic quarantine so um you know
the people came out of their houses
after that quarantine like a Baptist
after a casserole buying stuff buying
stuff left and right and so it went
crazy and it jammed up Supply Demand on
everything we called it supply chain
supply chain supply chain and all it was
was people are buying like nuts man and
so now now the Wall Street Journal
reporting today home prices aren't
falling anymore after declining on a
year-over-year basis for five
consecutive months which includes the
prices with the suckers I was talking
about the longest run of declines in 11
years US House Prices rose in July the
surprisingly quick
recovery which really wasn't her recover
I'm not surprised suggests that the
residential real estate downturn is
turning out to be shorter and shallower
than many housing economists expected
after mortgage rates soared last year
scarcity is a big
reason yeah Supply shortage hello yeah
High interest rates have prompted
homeowners to stay put rather than buy
new homes and take on more expensive
mortgages resulting in an unusually low
inventory of homes for sale no honey
there was already a lower inventory than
there was demand now it's even worse
because demand has even slowed because
of Interest mhm prices are generously
holding firm gen generally holding firm
outside of a few trouble spots the
national median existing home price Rose
1.9% in July it's almost 2% in one month
sheesh if you annualize that that's
24 I don't think we're going to see that
yeah but um even in a market where
demand has been hammered by higher rates
the supply just isn't there says the
chief Economist at
KPMG short of a flood in Supply it's
hard to see these prices coming down now
how would you get a flood in Supply well
you'd have to see a building boom and we
are seeing quite the opposite the number
of spec homes being built homes that
don't already have a buyer almost zero
wow completely dried up Builders quit
doing
them and so there's not is the opposite
of a flood of Supply there's a flood of
shortage that's coming so you're going
to continue to see real estate prices
climb we told you that oh by the way
we're doing another live stream where we
will also give you some more truth and a
year from now we'll say I told you so
about that too are you ready yes okay
this one's got Jade and me and Rachel
we're doing it tomorrow night for those
of you listening live it is
Tuesday the 12th that's when the event
is that's right it is the student loans
in America how we got here and how we'll
get out oo it's the get out part for me
Dave yeah that's meain we're not going
to talk about and gripe about all the
stuff it doesn't I mean how we got here
you can argue about that you can't argue
about how to get out cuz we' have
figured the the the there only one way
to get out the results are in it's not
Biden right survey says not B thank you
Richard Dawson Steve Harvey right survey
says Family Feud okay here we go but
either way we know that you are not
getting out from the Biden
Administration even the Biden
Administration knows that yeah they know
that and um cuz Supreme Court convinced
them of that that's an interesting move
so now here we go how you going to get
out what are you going to do well we're
not going to we're not going to beat you
up we know you're confused we know
you're scared um we know some of you are
mad and I don't blame you yeah but
listen uh we're going to show you how to
get out of student loan debt how we got
here and how to get out it's a free live
stream from the Ramsey solution Studios
tomorrow night at 700 p.m. central Time
sign up for it at Ramsey solutions.com
student loans you'll want to know this
information so a year from now when we
say I told you so you can say I was
there yes when he said that when she
said that that's right when Rachel Cruz
and Jade said that I was there and I did
it and then I did it there we go Ramsey
solutions.com studentloans free live
[Music]
stream
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians
share funds to pay for and pray for each
other's medical bills for over 40 years
chm has helped families living across
all 50 states so see if chm could be
right for your family check out more
today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at8
825-5222 Hi Sam welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi Jade thanks so much for
taking my call today I appreciate it
sure what's
up okay so I've got um it's a
complicated situation but I'm going to
try and simplify it as easy as best as
possible for you guys so I can just
honor your time so basically I have um
I'm completely debt free I've never had
any debt um very thankful to you for
that when I was 18 years old I took spu
before I went to college wow and
actually graduated fully debt free um
and so it was the best decision I ever
made so never known any debt I have a
fully funded emergency fund but about a
year ago I was given um a sum of money
from a family member um now the sum of
money that it was that I was given it
was kind of given with the pretext of
the reason why they had this money was
for a wedding or maybe to invest into to
give me to give for like my first
property that I would own but since kind
of know those things have happened they
decided I'm just going to give it to you
now um and I want you to do something
with it so in regards to like investing
or etc etc how much money is it my
problem is so it was
$20,000 okay cool that's
awesome yeah yeah so um so I guess my
next issue was more um I kind of don't
know what to do in the sense of I don't
know much in regards to Investments um
and since it was kind of sprung on me uh
of especially I think with the
attachment of going it was going to be
for maybe a wedding or maybe a house
deposit but that kind of hasn't happened
so do you not own a home I'm a bit are
you renting I don't no you're renting um
are you opposed to saving this I mean
you said that initially it was maybe for
a wedding maybe for a down payment why
wouldn't you set it aside and add to it
as a down
payment well I guess that's I guess
that's part of my question of just going
is that the best thing to do
um because I actually have no problem
with it I think what I've been
struggling with is because from this
family member it was kind of given the
the I'm giving you this money because I
want you to do something with it in
regards to investing it rather than it
just sitting in my bank account doing
nothing Well it wouldn't be doing
nothing I mean you you can put a mutual
fund and add to that mutual fund and
make that your down payment fund uh two
years from now 3 years from
now yeah yeah okay just go to ramseys
solutions.com just go to ramseys
solutions.com and click on
smartvestor and you'll find a group of
smartvestor Pros in the Daytona Beach
area you can choose from among them
which one you would like to work with
yeah and you want someone with the heart
of a teacher cuz it sounds like you're
new to investing
and they'll sit down and teach you about
investing only after you have learned M
and feel competent and comfortable
that's right do you invest and don't
ever invest in something you don't
understand but if I woke up in your
shoes I and if I had giving you that
gift with that guideline I would be
happy with you using some basic mutual
funds to let that be parked in until and
add some to it as you go along for a
future down payment yeah plan on having
it in there five years or so that's what
I'd say so it has some time to go in the
right direction yeah you should be able
to do great with it that should be
excellent easy Jill Is With Us in
Phoenix uh if I push the right button
Jill's there hi Jill's with us in
Phoenix hi Jill how are
you I'm well thank you so much thanks
for taking my call sure what's
up so I'm calling uh I've listened to
the show off and on for years but I got
really serious about six months ago and
um
I so I I'm gonna admit at the outst
start that I know I've messed
up but um I have about $100,000 of debt
with my ex-husband I'm currently married
um my current husband and I make good
money um because this debt felt so
overwhelming I kind of shoved it to the
side we paid off all of our other debt
um and I started saving for a house I
went to basically I skipped partial step
two and went to step three and we
started saving we paid so all your you
and your current husband paid off all
your other pre your debts from the other
marriage accept this debt and what is
this debt how big is
it it's
$100,000 and the IRS oh okay and how did
you end up $100,000 in debt to the
IRS so uh my former husband owned a
company um tax issues got complicated
um life was really overwhelming he
didn't want to deal with it I didn't
know how to deal with it so we just
didn't file seven years of
taxes yikes yeah so when we got divorced
wait minute wait minut did you have an
income during that time you personally I
did I did and you didn't file taxes on
that
income um so did you file taxes on your
income during the seven years no NOP
okay so his business was complicated you
didn't file on it and how did the
$100,000 come about who decided what
that
was so when we were getting divorced we
actually hired a CPA which is what we
should have done in the first place and
they went through filed all of our taxes
and let us know you know what we owed as
well as uh initially interest and
penalties and of course why in the world
did you file filing jointly or you're
going through a divorce why didn't you
file separately you would have only been
respons responsible for the taxes on
your
income the judge required it
unfortunately interesting I
know I don't believe
you I think your attorney mailed it in
judges that's not that's not logical the
judge required you file your freaking
taxes I don't I don't argue that but
though he didn't file you he didn't
require you you were as liable that
you're had to pay taxes on his business
that he didn't file
on uh so because the the judge basically
said while you benefited from the income
while you were married so you are both
jointly and severally liable and you
have to file together it was very very
frustrating so the ex I have a question
about your ex-husband is he going to if
you both said all right it's $100,000 I
pay 50 you pay 50 is he going to is he
going to do it no it's joint serval
she's leled for all of it until all
paid through the divorce um he is
obligated to pay 60% and I'm obligated
to pay 40 and that's kind of part of the
question
is try to pay the 40,000 no he's not no
he's not the divorce decree says that
but the IRS says you owe a
100 correct the IRS will not acknowledge
that exactly they don't have to if I pay
the hund and I can take him back to
court and sue him for that portion yeah
good luck with that or I know
and
honestly I it wasn't until I called a
smart investor Pro because I started
saving for a house and I had my
emergency fund I was savings for a house
and um your smart investor Pro was like
no no girl you got to go back to step
two you have to deal with this yes you
got to deal with it right so how much
money do you have laying
around so I have
$55,000 um part of that was money that I
got from uh my son passing away and part
of that is money we saved gosh okay I I
got to tell you there's a couple courses
you can go through here one course you
can go through is you can pay the
100,000 and hope you get his 40 back out
of him and I wouldn't give you much hope
for that and you move on with your life
that's a fairly easy course to take
that's the clean course that's the easy
one okay here's the one I would do
though and it's the hard one okay um I
would hire another CPA or rather a tax
attorney and I would go and uh go back
before the probate courts where the
where the divorce was done and challenge
that judge's ruling and refile under the
innocent spouse provision cuz I don't
think you're liable for his taxes and
you're innocent of his is the thing ask
your C ask your tax attorney about the
innocent spouse provision this is where
a spouse just signs off on everything
and the other spouse is running the
business and then and they just sign off
on it then they don't get half the thing
they get out they get out Scott for M
and you'd be liable for your income the
taxes on your income during that 7 years
but not on the business's income and I'm
challenging that judge's ruling if I'm
you it's going to cost you 10 grand to
do this I was going to say how much
would you spend to do that yeah and but
I would do it this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything cost too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
they make it easy and affordable to
upgrade your entire home and their team
is ready to help with everything from
design consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40% off everything sitewide
go to blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
busy week around here at Ramsey tomorrow
night Tuesday night we have the student
loan live stream how we got here how to
get out Jade washaw Ramy personality
along with Rachel Cruz will be my guests
on that live stream it's a free live
stream if you go to Ramsey solutions.com
student loans asign up it is Tuesday
night the 12th at 7:00 p.m. this weekend
if you're in the Chicago land area up
north of Chicago at Willer Creek Church
we are using their wonderful venue for
Friday evening and all day Saturday for
a smart conference Jade will be speaking
there along with George camel and Rachel
Cruz Dr John deloney Ken Coleman and me
it is a day and a half of uh fun
frivolity and you will leave exhausted
tired and smart it's a smart conference
and you can still sign up there are
still some tickets available ramsy
solutions.com it's our biggest event of
the year/ events bramsey solutions.com
events and Jade I don't know if you knew
this or not but um Bob borquez is uh
running the board today okay he's uh in
here helping us run the board I see you
Bob and uh Bob has been here
23 years wow as of today and U he and
just a full of other Ramsey team members
have been here for a quarter of a
century or so and Bob has been and and
here's what's weird about Bob he's been
in the radio area the entire
time that's weird well have you ever
heard his voice yeah I know he's got the
pipes and he's never done I mean we we
get Voice work out of him just because
he's here but he has never been done
professional Voice work for us in the
sense that uh we pay him for his voice
we pay him for being Bob that's what we
pay him for and uh lot of the 680 radio
stations that carry the Dave Ramsey I
mean the Ramsey show the Dave Ramsey
Show in the old days are there because
Bob called them and that was his job for
a lot of years calling radio stations to
get us on and a lot of the reason this
network is the size it is is because of
Mr Bob borquez we salute you today thank
you Bob very cool good stuff Morgan is
in Minneapolis hi Morgan welcome to the
ramsy
show hi thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up um so I have sort of
a complicated situation um my husband
and I are in the middle of a
construction project that should be
wrapping up here hopefully in the next
few weeks good um but my question is in
the meantime should we work the debt
snowball or should we try to attack our
credit card debt which is at the end of
our debt
snowball um to improve our credit scores
in the meantime since we have to
maintain good credit before we
refinance you have a construction
loan yes you've not been pre-approved
for your takeout
loan no not yet why how in the world did
you get the construction loan without a
pre-approved
takeout that's weird okay so you don't
have your permanent mortgage
arranged um I mean not
formally well that would be not yeah
okay
oh my gosh I'm scared um what's causing
that I don't know how they got their
construction loan very few people will
make a construction loan I mean what is
your all's net
worth Morgan
um Morgan I don't know the answer to
that right off hand okay you don't have
any but you don't have any money because
you have a bunch of credit card debt how
much credit card debt do you
have um just about
20,000 most of that relates to our
project project yeah bet and what's your
household
income um just under
100,000 okay and what is what do you owe
on the construction
loan um slightly over
300 goodness other debt any other
debt yes um we
have um
20 let's see trying to think here about
30,000 in student loans
okay are you current with everything
right
now yes we are okay this week go to
Churchill Mortgage yes and arrange for
your mortgage right
now okay because this house of cards may
fall in and if it does you're going to
lose this house and I want you to get
your I want you to get your permanent
Mortgage in place before this crap falls
apart okay because you have gotten
yourself into deep
debt and uh I'm I'm really afraid for
you right now you took on an awfully big
mortgage and you overran the budget on
the project and you did not have a
backdoor plan with in place with your
takeout mortgage and so you're in a very
tenuous situation so the first thing
you've got to do is immediately get a
mortgage in place to take out set up and
approved to take out this construction
loan and then once it's approved it
won't be a problem as long as you do it
in the next 30 days you're going to be
finished with a project you said in a
couple of weeks right yep okay so you
can get your Uno and get your appraisal
done and you guys can close you know
like by the end of the month or early
next month and be done inside of 30 days
here you got to get your mortgage in
place once that's done then we just
start working on the the debt snowball
with the student loan and the credit
cards but you're in a very tenuous place
because if you stub your toe before you
get approval on this permanent and I'm
worried about you getting approval you
got a really big mortgage based on your
income but if you can get approval you
don't want to St your toe you don't want
to miss you know these stinking student
loans they're due October 1st so you got
to have something in place to pay that
student loan payment October 1st and you
got to make sure all your credit cards
are paid on time between now and then so
you guys need to lay out a detailed
budget not miss a stinking thing until
you get this permanent in place once the
permanent mortgage is in place then
we'll back up breathe a little bit and
start attacking the rest of these debts
but you've left yourself very very
vulnerable here because if one little
thing goes sideways you you don't pay a
credit card on time uh you're not going
to get a because you got a real type
permanent mortgage your ratio is are
questionable as it is yeah and um you
got a mess girl that is a mess yeah you
guys completely uh jumped in the deep
end and not swimming so good so you got
to really really be careful with that
it's scary so Jade the thing you should
always do number one you shouldn't be
building a house if you got credit card
debt number two you should stay within
budget so you don't run up credit cards
to make the budget because you went over
budget on your house cuz you didn't keep
up with your dadgum numbers I'm building
the house right now the Builder just
sent me the spreadsheet on what we've
actually spent versus budget MH and it's
pretty simple formula yeah here's what
we've budgeted here's what we've spent
we're under budget we're over budget and
you can keep track of that every
stinking week with a builder if they've
got their uh stuff together okay
so and then you don't go for bud and you
don't pick stuff that doesn't fit you
know in the budget you know so no you
can't have that carpet and no you can't
have that tile and no that Appliance
isn't going in the kitchen you know you
don't have the budget that's not what
we're doing now in Sharon's and I case
if we decide to break the budget because
we see something we want to do we can do
that but we're doing that amongst a
bunch of information that gives us uh
the ability to make that decision wisely
what what what caused them to not take
out that take over that construction
loan earlier you can't get a permanent
mortgage on a house that doesn't have a
Uno you an occupancy permit if the house
isn't completed they won't make a a
traditional so it's that they're
overtime and over they're over not just
over buget they're over time as well no
no they have to finish you you could get
the you can get the takeout mortgage
approved subject to completion before
you break
ground before you even start the house
okay and that's what should have
happened but since they didn't do that
uh they can't get a mortgage in place
and pay off the construction loan the
mortgage won't be funded to pay off the
construction loan until completion oh
but you can get it all approved and
lined up and then if something goes
sideways doesn't matter already approved
okay they don't don't revisit and reapo
the mortgage six times during the build
they approve it one time give you a
letter says you're approved and at
completion we're going to fund the
mortgage that's simple and uh but you
can get in a real pinch in a situation
like this cuz they're because that bank
is going to want their money when the
house is completed yeah and you don't
have a permanent
you're in foreclosure instantly they're
going to want their money sh and so you
got to get a permanent or and you got to
get it up for sale one of the two and
boy that'd be sad that would be sad this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the church hill mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Church Hill
has bumped up their seller guarantee to
$10,000 giving your offer the best
chance of being accepted and helping you
win in today's market go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you for being with us America Jade
washaw is my co-host today Andre is with
us in Philadelphia hey Andre what's
up hey sir ma'am thank you for all you
do it's uh Good To Be Live I'm
definitely doing better than I deserve I
hear you what's up so uh let me do a
quick rundown I'm 32 um I bring in about
um
$4,000 um home um I have about 11,000 in
savings and uh Lord willing November
25th I'm going to get
married thank you I appreciate it so my
fiance has a situation she um she wasn't
really thought about finances and um she
bought a car last year that she thought
she was getting a good deal from
Enterprise basically 2019 Sentra 78,000
miles right now she owns 21,000 with 21
um interest rate uh so my whole thing
I'm trying to get out of that as soon as
I can um and the other thing is I'm
trying to we're trying to rebuild her
credit score but first one is the car um
I'm not sure I know I need to get just a
cheap carard just to get buy you don't
do anything till after November she
might do something but you don't do
anything you're not married yeah I agree
with that okay she owes 21,000 on the
car what's her
income her income is about three and a
half three and a half
what, $3500 a month okay so she makes
$40,000 a year sell the car
mhm yeah so the thing is the car it's
not worth that much money the most we
are getting for it or she is um is
around 12,000 so I have to make the
difference is$
7,000 how in the heck did she get so so
far upside no that's you got that bid
from a
dealer well there's no way I can we can
sell the car private because you don't
have the title for it she owns the money
to the I know I know yes yes there is
okay but the uh um so she's upside down
but she's not upside down
$77,000 doeses she have any money at
all no okay she's driving this car until
you get married then okay after you get
married you sell the car let's say the
car
brings 18 which is probably about what
it's worth okay if it brings 18 or I'm
sorry like you owe you owe yeah let's
say let's say you're $3,000 upside down
okay and I'm the buyer of the car now
you can check on this in Pennsylvania
but this is the way it goes down in Most
states okay I give you $118,000 for the
car you owe 20 and you don't have the
title you give me the car the keys and a
bill of sale that says that you have
sold me the car and uh then you add
2,000 or 3,000 of your money out of your
savings with your new wife now that
you're married after
November um with that and then you pay
the bank off and they send you the
title and then you say you give it to me
and I've bought cars that way I've sold
cars that way many times it's a standard
procedure with a private sale that has a
loan on it m uh the old days you would
go down to the bank and the bank
actually physically had the title there
at the bank and the buyer and the seller
would meet at the bank and you would pay
off the loan
with the proceeds of the purchase and uh
they'd hand the new guy the buy the
buyer the title but these days it takes
you know four or five weeks for the
stuff to get shipped around but this
gets you out of a
21% loan and a
$21,000 car with a $40,000 income which
is dumb it's got to go it's got to go so
I looked at at the on the value of the
card it's not worth more than 13 14,000
according to who and which value did you
look
at I looked at Kelly Blue Book I looked
at carvana I looked at private sale or
at
wholesale uh private sale so you got a
dealer to offer you 12,000 and your
saying Private Sales showing up as 13
one of those numbers is not right
Andre I guess I'll just have to look
into what's really going on there and um
yeah why why deers don't that dealers
don't buy $113,000 private sale cars for
12 they buy them for
nine okay so one of these because dealer
liks to make a spread that's what their
deal that's their business they're in
and so they're going to offer you
wholesale and wholesale is going to be
somewhere around 20% less than private
sale give or take and so just look at
that and you're so some because they
they got to make a margin that's the
business they're in so something's weird
about that um but either either way
whatever you do put the some of your
$1,000 to pay off the difference and
sell this car hopefully you can sell it
for more than you think you can I hope
you can so you don't use up as much of
your savings but you sell this car after
you get back from your honeymoon it's
gone 211% there's no reason to keep this
thing she got screwed six ways from
Sunday on this deal she overpaid for the
car and they saw her coming
and they hit her with 21% wait a minute
there's one other possibility I just
thought of once you look at something
else Andre uh if it's a 21% loan this is
a subprime loan they may be giving you
the account balance and not the
payoff 21,000 might not be the actual
payoff that may be the total of the
remaining payments including all the
interest the actual Bal because when
they do a ripoff subprime loan they put
it on the books as a total of payments
top and but that's not your payoff your
payoff doesn't include interest up
through the end of the loan and that
number includes interest through the end
of the loan now a traditional car loan
that's that's you know not screwing you
as bad um just puts it on the balance
puts the principal balance and that's
your payoff that's account balance is
principal balance it's not the same with
one of these screwed up uh 21% loans so
it's very possible that the payoff is a
lot less than you think it is so call
the the company that has it financed and
get the actual payoff if I send you a
check today so good what is the payoff
and I think you're going to find that to
be less a lot less that would make more
sense on the values that you're giving
me that does make more sense we've had a
couple of calls like that recently where
that's the case with these um subprime
loans what's the uh what's the gain from
the car dealership doing that just for
you to feel like I'm never getting out
of this you mean the fin comp yeah yeah
yeah uh yeah yeah they you feel like
you're stuck yeah and so you keep they
keep a 21% loan on the books cuz you're
stuck yeah you don't realize I can get
out of this yeah I'm SC I'm screwed for
life oh I hate that kind of thing and uh
it's a hope stealer I hate hope Stealers
yeah so um that sounds what you just
said that sounds that sounds accurate
that makes more sense with the numbers
he's looking up yes so I don't know
though well you have to dig into it and
find out but maybe you find out that the
payoff instead of 21 is 16 mhm uh which
is probably about the number and then
maybe the real private sale value is 14
and the dealer offer is you know 11 or
12 that starts to make a little bit I'll
go with that that one I might go with
and uh then you're still putting in two
or 3,000 bucks either way you're giving
up anywhere from two to $7,000 worth of
your money he's got to get out of that
after you get married but only after
you're married do not do do this until
the ring is on the finger and they need
to sit down and have a conversation
about how they're going to manage their
money going forward because it sounds
like he's still stepping in and trying
to you know save it and you know mold it
together but they really need to have a
conversation so they're both uh taking
charge here yeah yeah make sure you guys
are on the same page hey we'll help you
with that we'll put you into every
dollar and the every dollar premium and
financial pece University we'll give you
a little wedding gift and that that'll
give you you got some uh places to have
the conversation that's
right yes it's French yeah that's French
cuz now now you're going to be we not
not yeah but you were trying to he was
trying to be wee before he was there so
wait till you're married before you're
we don't be paying off other people's
debts that you're not married to yeah
that's called No No
Yeah no no here comes the we're going to
we're going to play this bad French
accent to the max take it all the way to
the top of the hour yes I'm committed
Dave I love it well hey it is very smart
to work together after you're married
but not before you're married uh don't
be paying each other's debts prior to an
actual marriage license having
been made official MH this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store
[Music]
today
Salah okay I'll get it right sorry about
that okay what's up tell me what's going
on all right so um some background I'm
22 years old I graduated college um I
got married a year ago or yeah about a
year ago and um I've got a baby on the
way which has been kind of the driving
factor in getting my Affairs in order
and
wonderful yeah so I my big thing is um I
you know I I know that I make you know
definitely gross over $100,000 a year
but I'm just struggling with you know
just balancing everything I feel like
somehow some way the money is not
stretching the way it should um you know
I come from a family who definitely
didn't make that much money and somehow
things felt different so I always
thought six figures would be that big
number but it's just not what it's not
what I thought it would be it's not as
much as it used to be is it just you
working or does your wife work as well
um my wife was working but we uh agreed
that once we um have a child that she
would uh that she would um be a primary
Homemaker and so she's not working down
up okay um so tell me a little bit more
about your debt to where you're feeling
like this 100K isn't what it used to
be okay so I um the primary debt that I
had when I first started getting into
credit cards I would just you know get a
0% interest and then flip it onto a with
a 0% intro offer for a balance trans and
I did that about three times so how much
credit card debt do you have so yeah now
I'm sitting at about uh at 6,000 in
outstanding debt that doesn't include
the month-to-month cards that I'm paying
but those are almost paid down to zero
um probably like a thousand between the
three or four cards um I pay those fully
month to month but the one the two that
are on 0% interest uh those they end in
March and and they're about 6 ,000
What's the total amount of the debt all
the Balan toal amount like probably
9,500 I believe okay what else do you
have uh I have 5,500 in student loans
that of course just started being uh due
for repayment and my wife also has about
10,000 in student loans okay um how much
on your
cars oh no cars we I'm a car guy so we
own our cars out right okay what's your
mortgage no mortgage I rent so wait a
second much is your rent 1,500 a month
okay and how long you how long ago did
you start trying to follow our stuff a
month or
two it's been like three months but I
mean I didn't really have much income to
go off of initially I I started I'm an
Uber driver I have a full-time job uh
with my degree in in effectively in in
it and I uh I also started Uber driving
um and I started kind of kicking that
into high gear to try to get these
credit cards paid off and that's been my
Avenue yeah okay so so you're just
getting started and you've not really
gotten the budget dialed in yet no
that's really all this is because I'm
looking at a guy who makes $100,000 a
year you got $25,000 of student loan
debt or of debt period um actually less
than that so I don't think it's a lot of
debt but I don't think it's
the big fire and exploding thing that
you think it is in your head I think
that if you guys get on a simple budget
and you live on $8,000 instead of
$100,000 you're knocking this debt out
super fast that's that's if you just
okay we're going to we're going to cut
back but if you really got crazy you
knock this out very quickly yeah beans
and rice rice and beans a detailed
written Budget on the every dollar app
you and your wife agree that we are
doing
nothing except eat and diapers mhm and
electricity and pay rent that's that's
it nothing we're doing nothing until we
get this paid off and $2,000 a month and
you are free in one year yeah you guys
are newly married you got a baby on the
way you guys have been spending a lot
that's that's what I'm seeing here well
and I I'll add to this I I'll take up
for you just a little bit you live in a
very high tax High Cost of Living town
oh that's also true Connecticut is the
highest taxed state in the
Union and uh Hartford is a Beau full
Town very
expensive
agreed yeah I just that's kind of my big
thing is I know it's a 100 gross but I
mean after taxes it's definitely not 100
I know it's not I know it's not but you
can do this you can still live on even
in spite of that you can do this okay
this is doable in New York City it's
doable in LA and so it's doable in
Hartford and thankfully you have a good
rent situation too so that's good so I
think the thing is the the piece that'll
come to this is you and your wife are in
agreement that for a short period of
time we're going to live like no one
else so that later we can live and give
like no one else including super big
time take care of this baby MH and so
you have a new reason to delay pleasure
that's and that's adults devise a plan
and follow it and children do what feels
good you're going to do great so we're
going to give you a uh a a gift to say
uh congratulations on a new baby woohoo
and help you get started on all this and
we appreciate you following us on
YouTube and the gift is we want you to
gu you and your wife to go through
Financial Peace University and get
signed up in the every dollar app the
world's best budgeting app and it'll
break every one of your paychecks down
for you it'll show you how to use the
baby steps exactly and Financial Peace
University will teach you the things you
should have been taught about money but
weren't taught the things we all should
have been taught about money but we
weren't taught and um so we're going to
give you every bit of that and it's
completely free you hang on Austin will
pick up and we'll get you signed up for
that Jade one of the things we saw with
the every dollar app you've been doing
some of these every dooll webinars Y is
that um showing people how to do the
budget by the way you can sign up for
those if you just go to everydollar.com
budgeting and Jade Jade will be doing
those and Rachel Cruz and George camel
as well um anyway one of the things
we're finding is we've always said it
feel like you get a raise when you're on
a budget yes but we've actually found a
piece of research of day said you it
literally is 10 to 15% of a year yeah
well most people are finding
$332 extra that's just money that they
were piddling away at Target groceries
yeah they're able to find that money
that I mean so when you happen to your
money instead of the lack of money
happening to you MH the efficiency
increases yeah you get a raise and you
it'll feel like you got a raise and then
you don't use that raise to go buy a new
car so what most people do most people
get a $232 raise and go take out a $400
car payment to celebrate no no no no no
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
thank you for joining us America our
question of the day is brought to you by
by neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly has 19 service Brands
Nationwide and a network of local
service pros Molly made Mr Rutter
plumbing and Mr Appliance just to name a
few visit neighborly decom to find
available service providers near you
today's question comes from Rachel in
Florida she says I have a quick question
I just transitioned from baby step 2 I
have a little over 60,000 in school
loans when I'm looking at my debt from
smallest to biggest do I look at the
school loans indiv ually uh which would
make them a list of smaller loans or
should I look at it as a whole which
would put them at the end of my debt
snowball yeah I would look at them as
individual cuz most of us took out you
know a giant amount right but they blast
them into all these little pieces and
generally they have their own interest
rates and all that but and they have
their own payment they have their own
payment when that one's paid off that
payment goes away that's right and by
the way yeah let's talk about that for a
second because let's say oh I have
30,000 in student loans but it's
technically you know six or eight or 10
little micro loans right when you make
your payment every month a piece of that
goes to every single one of those so if
you are doing a debt snowball for
instance and you're listing them from
smallest to largest along with your
other debt whenever you make your
minimum student loan payment that is
satisfying all of those small loans and
then when you're ready to make an extra
payment you pick the student loan that's
the smallest you've a lot of times got
to call it in and say I want all of this
money to go to the principal this
specific loan because if you don't do
that they're just going to consider that
a pay ahead payment and they're going to
split it up on all the loans again and
you're never going to make any Headway
right so that's very important um and a
very good question so yeah list them and
order as smallest to largest and do it
like I just said and you'll be good to
go yeah exactly because that way see
when you eliminate that $3,400 one you
don't have that payment anymore exactly
so your minimum payment goes down as
well and exactly cuz your your total of
payments go goes down yeah that's right
and the whole process then you're
getting the benefit of the snowball see
the benefit of the snowball folks is
that when you pay off a loan the payment
you used to have there is now freed up
money and it goes to the next one and
that gives you extra you've got more
disposable income to pay extra on debts
every time the snowball rolls over and
you have this satisfaction of traction
you're in a you're in a psychological
feedback loop this says you're winning
yes and when you have a sense of
hey I'm I'm doing this exercise I'm
following this eating regime and
therefore I'm losing weight you've got a
feedback loop there that tells you to
keep doing it that's right and uh so
that's a big deal that's a huge deal all
right Curtis is with us in Lancing
Michigan hi Curtis welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you for having me been a
big fan for a few years
now cool how can I help so I was
followed all your stuff um bought your
book and everything about 3 4 years ago
got my car paid off all my credit cards
paid off and then I took probably about
50 steps backwards and stopped listening
and kind of Life hit me and I you know
quit my job wanted a better job and went
to school so I just got done with school
and I'm just been working out for about
two months at my new job and I just kind
of want to know I got student loans
coming up um I got everything on my
bills set out for the month and I'm only
with the student loans coming up I got
to get you know car repair um it's not
looking too good for me and I'm going
back to school full-time in January
so um well I for my job I kind of have
to that was kind of the um kind of
signing on that was one of the
requirements I go back but you're you're
not going into more debt right you're
going to pay cash or figure out a way
they paying for it
so so it's kind of difficult that part
because uh a I'm a firefighter so I have
to go back for paramedic school and the
townships they're in talks right now of
paying for it which we get right now a
bonus every year of 3,000 if I'm a
paramedic so it will kind of pay itself
in the next few years so yes I'm going
to have to make a monthly payment on it
I won't be able to take student loans
out on that so it's going to be about
$300 a month
um on top of the student loans I
actually owe starting next month um so
that's kind of where I'm at with that so
hopefully they can pay it but I'm not
going to you know count on that I'm just
going to pay it monthly but then I was
wondering if I took a personal loan out
or a consolidation loan and just pay it
all off and have one big payment
nope okay nope um no shortcuts that that
work and that that one doesn't work
doesn't that doesn't help you it
actually hurts you uh in general you may
raise the interest rates as a matter of
fact the loan the thing where they're
taking out of your pay for the paramedic
school hadn't G any
interest true and that loan would have
interest so there's one part and another
one you got might be a lower interest
than the consolidation loan interest is
and so net net net you end up paying
more getting screwed over by one of
these debt con solidation deals so what
are you making now as a
firefighter so for a probation you know
first year uh we started out at 46 and
then the next four years I would get a
10,000 increase and be topping out about
76 78 after four years and then we get
you know little bonuses throughout the
year um which that's not included in the
the 46 for the first year how much
student loan debt have you taken out
total what do you owe so
just
4500 okay and then you mentioned a car
repair is that is that
it um car repair and then I am currently
kind of behind on been working my butt
off trying to get uh everything caught
up bills wise uh I bought my house about
five years ago so I should end of
October I should be all caught up on
everything that I kind of got behind on
what caused you to get
behind uh just School working you know
by myself um screwing around not paying
attention pretty much and then you know
two two and a half years of schooling
fulltime and that doesn't cause you get
you you you had the you were making
money during that time you could have
paid your bills you just weren't paying
attention yeah so you have got to you've
got hey man you you got to own this and
you got to step up and step into it and
say this ends today I don't think it
takes till October to get this mess
cleaned up how far behind are
you so I am about 2 months behind on
like my water and it's just all been
I've been you know got half of them up
so yeah so you're doing fire you're on
probationary fire so you're doing 24 on
are 48 on 48 off uh 24 on 24 off or 24
on 48 off yep so it's 24 on 24 off 24 on
24 off 24 so you have a lot free time
for your nice juicy extra job side
hustle uhhuh and I want you working all
the time next so should I because I was
thinking about getting a second job yeah
six of
them but then I I was wondering because
I can pick up a lot of overtime and I
also can do on call whatever to makeever
pays you more yeah okay so I want you to
work all the time hey are you behind on
your rent or mortgage at
all um not not behind to where I'm like
30 not even 30 days behind so almost two
months but this next paycheck I should
be all caught up until the next month
your stress level's killing
me yeah it's been uh so I just kind of
pick myself up you know good good I'm
glad okay now that you picked yourself
up let's run let's run hard run hard man
I want you to go make a bunch of money
as much money as you can make in the
shortest possible period of time legally
and morally I want you working all the
time and I don't want you doing anything
but working and paying bills I don't
want you partying I don't want you going
on vacation I certainly don't want you
eating out you eat at the fire station
and you eat cheap ramen noodles peanut
butter and jelly dude I mean you are
getting out of debt you are sick and
tired of being broke and you get fired
up and wired up you can clean this mess
up really fast you are kicking the can
down the road again with some of this
it's dragging out and dragging out and
dragging out and I want you to lean on
your supervisor they need to pay for
this if they're requiring paramedic
school they ought to pay for it that's
right they ought to pay for it and I
know the township has to approve it well
let me just tell you you got a young
firefighter here who's asking you to pay
for it and you're requiring it you ought
to pay for it that's right so Step Up
push in push in push in push in Hustle
grind hustle grind push this out clean
this mess up and get it behind you this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us America in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the Deb free stage Matt and
Sarah are here hey guys how are you
doing great welcome where do you guys
live Elwood Illinois which is just
outside of Poria yeah fun welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
paid off about
$200,000 excellent how long did this
take about 5 years and four months 5
years and four months way to go and your
range of income during that time about
82,000 up to about
124,000 oo where go what do you all do
for a living I'm a territory rep for an
a company mhm and I was an elementary
teacher for six years and now I stay at
home cool very good good what kind of
debt was this 200,000 uh it was about
40,000 in student loans and then the
rest was our house you paid off your
house yes looking at weird people all
right how old are you to uh I just
turned 29 yesterday and I'm 28 and you
have a paid for house sir that's
whacked way to go none of your friends
do way to go guys so weird in such a
good way yeah excellent excellent what's
this house worth uh it's about 300,000
today excellent very cool and how much
you guys got in your investment so far
uh just over 100,000 excellent so you're
almost a half a million dollar net worth
already and you're not even 30 sheesh
boom boom I love you guys you're amazing
wow that's inspiring so what happened
five years and four how long y'all been
married uh six years okay so you got
married and said game on how does that
work yeah actually started before we got
married so during our premarital
counseling our pastor Pastor Marty just
shared the struggles that people have
with uh money fights and money problems
and he shared you you with us and gave
us the book and we left that meeting
just determined not to be uh to have
money fights or money problems not to
fall victim to what most people do yeah
exactly that's very smart yeah and so we
kind of left that meeting and uh we sat
down we we really just budgeted and that
became our our Focus we sat down we
budgeted every month we had our meetings
uh I knew the day that we were looking
at our budget and Matt was like no
orange juice we're not getting any more
orange juice we were cutting the budget
Matt went for the orange juice line in
the budget yes so we really looked at
the budget and tried to figure out
anything that we could cut and we just
threw everything uh at our debt so wow
so how much orange juice were y'all
buying
g128 but old ma got it I'm just saying
count counts hey it all counts and
that's really what we learned is if you
can really find anything in your budget
that you can cut cut and just throw that
at the debt it goes goes quickly yeah
pretty amazing what happened to get this
income up you went from
82,2 4,000 and you started staying at
home so explain that a little bit Yeah
so well our income now is down out about
uh 84,000 today with her staying at home
but during that time it was just gradual
raises and then I took a u promotion at
work uh to become the the sales rep I
was working in the factory but now I um
got a sales rep we were able to move
closer to home too a wow so you got the
freedom now to stay home you get to feed
the stay at home mom wow I love this at
29 years old 28 years old that's Pretty
stinking cool very cool very very neat
yeah that's uh that's like too much
common sense to be believed I mean yeah
okay my pastor says the main thing
people struggle with is money fights
we're not going to do that yeah oh there
you go so how many money fights have you
had very few I'd say very few take out
the orange juice none ex okay that is
great well it's different when you have
money like it's different when you're
both going on a trajectory and the the
discrepancies or the arguments are more
about how how can we get there faster
right as opposed to you spent and no you
spent like it's a very different feeling
yeah and i' I'd say that we you know I
said we find any way that we could to
save money and you know we were taking
online uh tests to get $10 a test and we
decided we had some woodworking talents
and some crafting talents so we started
a small business and you know we just
try to find anything that we could to um
to just start paying off the debts and
now that we're out of it it's it's
almost hard to spend money now I have to
trying to push her to actually spend
money on you know spend 20 bucks on
buying something or buy that $4 coffee
or whatever that mindset out honey I
want you to get all the
oranges I like it that's very good so
what is next what do you you got a paid
for home no not a payment in the world
how's that feel it's awesome it's
awesome it's hard to describe but it's
just just awesome there's no stress no
that just like a weight lifted off your
shoulders and I think we we brought home
our son and you know in a couple weeks
after we brought him home we we paid off
our house and you know we're sitting
there on the couch just looking at our
newborn child and we're like wow we we
live and we own this house and it
just great feeling and you're going to
be freaking loaded in a couple of years
little boy things are going to be okay
oh yeah I like it well done y'all very
well well done I'm with Jade what what's
your first big thing now that you're
debt free well right now we're just
adjusting to the one inum now but
hopefully in the next year or two maybe
a big trip like we've always wanted to
go to Alaska or back to Europe again
yeah oh definitely do both you got to do
it not or both yeah y you lived like no
one else now you can live and give like
no one else ex you put yourself in a
position to change your family tree and
uh your kid is going to get to do things
and see things you never thought you
would do MH and that's what's happened
to us it's pretty cool and my grandkids
now now they get to do stuff that would
have completely was outside my realm of
reality I didn't even know it existed of
course it didn't exist some of it but
but way to go guys so proud of you who
was bragging on you and cheering you on
as you went along definitely our family
has a big impact on us and they showed
us what it was to love and give and uh
we're so excited to be able to do that
now uh we were even going to be teaching
Financial Peace University uh we start
our first class on Monday thank you our
church so you'll be great coordinators
very excited argue with me I'm not even
30 and got a paid for M drop M drop
don't try it love it way to go yeah my
pastor used to say that a man with an
opinion is or a man with an experience
is not at the mercy of a man with an
opinion I know that's and you now have
an experience so uh yeah everybody's
opinions don't matter you just grin and
go well you just don't get it
exactly wow well done well done thanks
for teaching the class that's amazing
good good stuff all right now when
you're teaching the class you're not
even 30 years old I'm going to say it
over and over so people hear this you
have a paid for house what do you tell
them the key to getting out of debt is
uh for me it was like not comparing to
to anyone else not caring what anyone
else's think you know live your own life
do it the way you you taught to do it or
what's right in your eyes don't care
about what everyone else thinks don't
live up to the
Joneses uh for me it was definitely
budgeting I think uh I live with an
ultra Ultra Ultra nerd and like he's
looking at the budget every night and uh
so he's at the orange juice level of
nerd that's a different level of nerd
micro and uh and for us it was that that
budget and uh taking time and having a
meeting and I think we grew so much
together just having those conversations
and because he is the alterer I use that
time to learn and I ask question him up
you know yeah of course he's the one
that's always trying to tell me to spend
money so I might be a little titer now
that we got there he he's a he's task
oriented now we got the task done that's
exactly it's in the budget now we have
to line on him it's in the budget we
have the fre we have to put fun in there
now we have to do something fun with
that money yeah I like it hey we've got
the baby steps millionaires book for you
in the live and give box a Financial
Peace University membership you'll be
able to bless someone and have them come
through your class and you can give them
a free membership that way same with The
Total Money Makeover book it's all the
live and give box and uh just to say
thank you for coming down and in your
dead free scream we're so proud of y'all
you guys are a power couple man cool
you're amazing and you brought little
guy with you what's his name his name is
Weston Weston is how old eight months
and he's got his Dead free scream
earphones on so he's not going to freak
out hopefully we maybe he'll never know
it happening a scream but we do have the
video of the day that his life was
complete his family tree was completely
changed that's pretty cool we'll have
that excellent stuff Matt Sarah and
Weston Peoria Illinois 200,000 paid off
how house and everything 5 years and 4
months making 82 to 124 count it down
let's hear a debt-free Scream 3 2 1
we're de
free
yeah oh yeah he got through the
earphones he's
screaming it's so fun well done
hopefully hopefully we don't have any
permanent damage there that's his that's
his debt free scream
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Isaiah 263 you
will keep in perfect peace those whose
minds are steadfast because they trust
in
you Jimmy Buffett rest in peace it takes
no more time to see the good side of
life than it takes to see the bad there
you go little Margaritaville for you all
right up next is going to be laser laser
is in New York hi laser welcome to the
Ramsey Show hello hi thank you for
taking my call um I have a question I
recently uh started listening to you
guys and I'm here in baby step 2 looking
forward to re and Beyond and I'm
wondering about the efficacy of
investing in uh mutual funds in the
stock market based on many of the people
buying from those companies are using
debt to do
so the ethics of that correct if I'm if
I'm investing putting my money into
companies that are going to make me a
make me a profit through people using
debt if I don't believe in debt anymore
okay
um well that's you know it would depend
on what what level or what type of
Ethics you're talking about uh for
instance uh I've got a good friend who
is Muslim who has talked to me and
taught me some of the things that the
Quran says uh and so if you're Muslim
there's very strict uh Usery rules from
a religious
perspective uh user being anything
having to do with interest Judaism I'm
sorry I'm Jewish and there's as well for
Usery with in in in the Bible yes user
is in the Christian Bible as well but
the Muslim view of us is anything
associated with interest you're
forbidden to participate in and that's
not true of Judaism and Christianity
it's just Usery and Judaism and
Christianity generally I mean there's a
few different groups that might nuanced
uh differently but but most of the time
that uh my uh that that your tradition
or my tradition are talking about us
it's excessive interest now I'm with you
I don't believe in debt you know that
you called Dave Ramsey and Jade B you're
talking about debt we hate debt and we
get people out of debt and we don't do
anything at Ramsey to put people in debt
we don't even take credit cards in our
online store you can only use a debit
card because that would be very
hypocritical in our case uh uh however
then I've gotten questions from other
people that are once removed and yours
is a little bit on that line so let
let's
um let me think how to equate this from
an Ethics perspective it's almost like
you are not in control of other people's
behaviors and you can't control them and
there's no set of Ethics that demand
that you
do and so um if someone buys one of my
books with a credit card on Amazon I
can't control that
I don't have the only way I could
control it is to not have the book on
Amazon uh or I can't control it if they
go to Barnes & Noble and use a credit
card now it's it's humorously
stupid yeah it
is but it's not unethical yeah yeah okay
I don't see how it's different than
using a credit card and getting credit
card points of investing in the stock
market and making profit off people
other people's
de well the the profit for instance
let's just say like take Home Depot okay
uh Home Depot makes their profit off of
two things the sale of uh construction
materials and hardware and they have a
huge operation called The Home Depot
credit card so some of Home Depot's
profits are from the credit card
Division and that would be true of
almost every single company in America
for that matter of any size that would
be traded on the stock market uh
certainly all the banks make money off
of debt uh that's their Prime almost
everything they make is off of debt um
and so you know if you bought a mutual
fund that bought Bank of America's stock
and the Bank of America stocks went up
your point is that you know then my
mutual fund has profited but that's so
many layers removed from me putting them
into debt that I don't see the ethical
Pro the ethical issue if if you do see
an ethical issue laser I don't require
that you do it um and generally when
someone does that they're doing it more
on a religious basis than they are a
pure ethics basis it's a religious
ethics and that's driving um driving
someone to that and so you know another
way another example that kind of similar
question that we get into sometimes is
uh uh in investing not investing in
companies uh from a Christian or a
Jewish perspec that are engaged in sin
mhh uh and so you wouldn't buy into a
mutual fund if it bought um uh a liquor
stock or a cigarette stock or a whatever
okay but that again you know you you
it's very difficult to parse all of
those things out and keep up with it
because also if I buy a stock from you
and you profit from me buying a stock
from you uh that has nothing to do
that's like me buying a Chevrolet from
you and you made a profit yeah or I
bought a uh some you you collect shoes
the Air Jordan shoes I buy some of those
and you made a profit none of that
profit went to Nike and none of that
profit went to Michael Jordan that's
right so if you don't agree with Nike
and don't agree with Michael Jordan you
and I doing that transaction does not
send them a profit Chevrolet doesn't
make any money if I buy a Chevrolet from
you yeah that's they made money on the
initial sale of the car to the first
person down the line but when so when
you're trading stocks back and forth uh
the person you're buying from is who's
making the money there now he is correct
though in saying that the stock goes up
in value based on the profitability of
the company and the profitability of the
company is because people went into debt
that's right that is a correct conundrum
that is a correct U ethical quandry that
he's asking about I I have not been
bothered by me controlling other
people's behavior I have to control what
I engage in yeah and that's my ethics
but I can't I can't make you do
something in the name of my ethics yeah
that is a very it's definitely something
it's it's an interesting thought to
think about at the very least it's very
conscious it is very conscious but I do
you know I've been sitting here thinking
about it and I really think it's um you
can't control other people's behavior
and I think that's the bottom line um
some people are going to buy things they
can't afford and go into Deb and doing
so and when that happens yeah that's
going to make somebody's profits go up
and their Stock's going to go up um but
like you said that's really good it's so
far removed from you you didn't tell
them to do that no one told them to do
that no one caused them to do that other
than themselves it's kind of like this
they the
um you know I can't buy stock and Pizza
Hut because some of their pizzas are
sold on credit cards okay that's as
nuanced as then you probably can't buy
gas at your corner convenience store
because they sell pornography I mean you
could go you could go down the line with
that you could say well I won't buy a
stock in Pizza Hut because it's a
caloric food and it causes obesity and
Glutton Glutton ah I mean you could go
is that what happened to
me now I know I'm a
victim I thought it was my
fault look I mean that's the thing
there's so you can go down that road in
so many making fun of you laser I'm
making fun of me but yeah laser Laser's
got a valid he does question of
conscience don't violate your conscience
anytime you're doing any investing or
money transactions and money is a good
subject area to test your
conscience okay I'll tell you another
thing another reason you can't buy gas
at the corner stock market Market they
sell Lottery lottery tickets D yes and
that's the ultimate in gambling and it's
a tax on poor people because 80% of the
lot lottery tickets P purchased
Nationwide are purchased in lower income
zip codes yeah so um and the rest of
them are purchased by people who don't
do math yeah and so um or can't do math
and or haven't chosen to do math so that
it you just it's hard to go to that
level of jot and tit to use an old King
James phrase uh the the mintia and the
detail let's use a different well it's
the mintia and the detail is what it Ms
to if you go into the the the the Nuance
it you can get to legalism real quick
and you don't want to get to legalism
then you're looking at everything you're
looking at you almost have to pick your
battles cuz where things are
manufactured yeah what type of Labor
what were the like you can really go
pretty much going to be in a cave yeah
that's sad that it's on everything H
have stay out there swinging in the
culture and having impact that way that
puts us hour the ramsy show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to ramsy solutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's ramsy
solutions.com and click get
started